depuis plus de 30 ans vous vous battez
pour être reconnue comme la fille d'yves
montand immense star il monte en jeu ne
connaissent pas c'est unanime enchanteur
et l'immense acteur voilà et cette série
qu'un combat judiciaire qui a connu
d'énormes rebondissements sans d'être si
on doit signaler qu'une décision de
justice a été rendue et dit que vous
n'êtes pas la fille d'yves montand c'est
en 75 aurore que votre mère anne vous
donne naissance alors quand quand est-ce
que vous commencez à vous quand est-ce
qu'elle commence à vous dire que vous
êtes probablement la cie du montant en
fait c'était à la maternelle
d'abord il y avait la fête des mères
donc là j'étais contente de faire une
petite peinture pour la fête des mères
et puis quelques semaines après la fête
des pères est là bas je ne savais pas du
tout ce qui était un père donc du coup
on a un petit peu honte on a tous non
des joyeux heureux et puis bah on ne
sait pas ce que c'est donc je je suis
rentré à la maison et c'est la première
chose que j'ai demandé à ma mère c'est
quoi un papa est bon bah moi dans ma
petite naïveté je regardais les tex
avery et c'est donc du coup je pensais
que j'étais né d'une rose une cigogne
est venue des me déposer devant chez ma
mère parce qu'elle voulait enfin voila
moi ça c'était comme ça jusqu'à cet
instant puis elle m'a dit ben non non tu
es comme tout le monde tu as un papa
aussi voilà le mois il m'explique alors
justement on a une vidéo de votre maman
anne qui raconte d'ailleurs sa rencontre
avec yves montand
brossard en week end à saint paul de
vence en même temps que mon temps
en aurait profité pour lui laisser un
message lui demandant de pouvoir le
rencontrer et le lendemain matin à 8
heures le téléphone a sonné
j'étais en peignoir pas du tout prête à
sortir et il m'a dit je crois que vous
voulez voir ce midi je peux pas mais
avant revanche l'as si vous êtes libre
on peut prendre le petit déjeuner sera
pourquoi pas mais je suis pas prête
c'est pas grave je monte à il est monté
[Musique]
salon remercier jean marc morandini
carson prod en voilà pour ces images
soient ya crime d'ailleurs et donc voilà
donc la pas le raconte l'histoire donc
elle a vu comme une fois en fait mon
temps c'est l'assurance et une relation
de deux ans qui a été prouvé lors des
deux des deux ans d'enquêtés judiciaires
lors des premières des cinq premières
années qui ont mené à ma reconnaissance
officielle ou quand en 1994
pas donc sur une simple ressemblance
mais sur une véritable enquête
judiciaire avec donc des policiers qui
ont passé au crible fin tout le monde
montant son entourage ma mère m'aime moi
j'ai été interrogé vous avez essayé de
rencontrer votre mais papa donc ce
montant mais tout s'est pas passé comme
prévu non alors du coup effectivement
[Musique]
à 6 ans en fait ma mère avait l'habitude
parfois de téléphoner pour essayer de
provoquer en fait des rencontres
j'avais d'ailleurs rencontrer simone
signoret déjà de la seule personne
bienveillante toute la famille avec moi
alors voir appliquer
benjamin c'était la femme du bon temps
et ma concernant exacto et du coup je
l'avalé vous a parlé je l'avais
rencontré oui quand j'étais petit
elle a essayé d'intervenir auprès de
dives mon temps quand il a appris que l
avais discuté avec ma mère s'en fait ma
mère comme je vous dis appelé
régulièrement la plupart du temps lui
raccroche au nez et ce soir là elle
était tombée sur simone et du coup
elle a essayé en fait d'intercéder et et
il est rentré dans une colère noire et
voulait pas entendre parler moi voilà et
donc effectivement plus tard donc à 6
ans
comme mon temps
[Musique]
militait pour le syndicat polonais
solidarnosc
de par nos origines polonaises donc ma
mère s'est dit tiens je vais l'appeler
on sait jamais et puis ce genre là donc
elle tombe sur lui et lui raccroche
poney et est là pour le coup elle était
la première étonnée et cette fois il a
voulu me parler donc je les ai eus au
téléphone jour là et il a voulu me
rencontrer donc je lui ai dit qu'en est
il m'a dit tout de suite et donc un
petit peu en panique
du coup ma mère n'a pas voulu
venir avec moi pour éviter qu'ils en
intervenir dans la rencontre donc je
suis allée avec ma baby sitter de
l'époque
sauf que du coup le temps que ça
s'organise on est arrivés en retard il
ya eu des témoins entre temps il est
avec des personnes du coup de
solidarnosc et j'ai passé le portail
enfin le porche et je me suis retrouvé
face à face avec lui on s'est regardé
longuement les yeux dans les yeux et
puis là la personne de solidarnosc à
côté a coupé un peu ce long silence et
détient kéké cette petite fille et là il
s'est repris et puis l'a fait au nom
c'est rien c'est rien du tout encore une
femme sait rien et là j'étais abasourdi
jeu
j'aurais pu crier que j'étais sa fille
mais en fait non j'étais
voilà je n'ai qu'à l'âge de 6 ans 10 ans
donc j'ai pris ma baby sitter en fait
par la main et très fièrement on est
reparti car le même porsche rouge a été
si heureuse quelques instants avant ou
me disant qu'est ce que ça va être de
rencontrer mon père avec six ans de
retard alors que j'avais déjà rencontré
sa femme
et là ça a été vraiment je me suis
sentie rejetée bama la première fois que
j'ai eu envie de mourir j'avais 6 ans
voilà après la rencontre puisque du coup
on a l'impression dans l'est rien envie
de mourir à 6 ans ouais j'en voulais à
mon père de m'avoir rejetée du coup là
c'était assez violent en fait j'en
voulais à ma mère de m'avoir mis au
monde donc en fait c'était j'avais envie
de mourir la première fois vous l'aï
plus jamais revu
si j'ai revu du coup plus tard en 89
1 ap restait que vous saviez qu'elle ait
comment vous aviez qu'elle avait
pourtant donc j'avais 13
accords
et balla c'était juste avant que le
procès ne commence
puisque du coup quand ma mère à l'époque
si vous voulez avait annoncé qu'elle
était enceinte il lui avait dit oh bah
chouette ça peut peut-être de moi parce
qu'elle 54 ans peut pas avoir d'enfant
et basse à lui après deux ans au bas
dommage on était bien mais ça lui est du
coup voilà elle se retrouvait
donc tout seul à ce moment là et là
effectivement quand j'avais 13 ans alors
que très sincèrement depuis mes 6 ans je
voulait plus en entendre parler en fait
quand on dit que j'ai grandi dans le
culte d'yves montand
que je voulais lui ressembler pas du
tout
loin de là si j'avais dû inventer un
père ça n'aurait pas du tout été lui met
un grand maître d'arts martiaux
et voilà enfin et tout d'un coup ils
s'affichent en fait ils clament partout
dans la presse quelle joie d'être papa
pour la première fois à 68 ans donc
voila et là ça a été le deuxième coup de
poignard pour moi donc alors que je
rentrais dans un collège où jean total
anonyme je voulais pas dire aux gens
m'a donné sur les fiches
d'identification le nom mon père et c
est là bas voilà quand on veut faire
table rase du passé qu'on a un père
célèbre voilà on peut pas
entamer du coup cela procédure mais
avant l'avocat nous a dit essayer quand
même de passer quand même à l'amiable
encore une dernière fois finalement
quand vous avez 19 ans le célèbre j'ai
vu la justice va d'abord vous
reconnaître comme la fille d'yves
montand ouais alors là c'est une
libération pour un bateau tan oui parce
que justement moi c'est
vrai j'ai eu des événements aussi quand
j'étais petit qui ont amené une question
en fait primordiale c'est si ma mère
disparaissait il a eu un accident de
voiture elle a fait un moment une
tentative de suicide donc déjà tout
petit je me dis bah ouais mais alors si
ma mère elle disparaît parce que je sais
le nom de mon père devant la loi en fait
je suis la fille de personnes donc du
coup s'il lui arrive quelque chose bah
il n'a pas le devoir la responsabilité
par rapport à la loi de 2.2 mois
quelques années plus tard la justice a
plus loin décidé d'exhumer le corps
d'yves montand tu es le résultat tombe
pour la justice vous n'êtes pas la fille
du montant finalement alors un
retournement de situation là vous dites
quoi alors là c'est la vraie reprendre
en fait depuis
après le jugement en fait à dire que
deux ans plus tard tout d'un couteau moi
j'ai eu gain de cause j'étais reconnu
officiellement fille d'yves montand sur
des éléments sérieux factuel des
témoignages etc son double refus de
faire le test etc et
et du coup mince j'ai perdu le nom là il
exhume le film est en fait le truc c'est
que tout d'un coup catherine allégret à
carole amiel donc en 96 en leur nom
décide alors que le père est décédé moi
j'ai gagné elle décide de reprendre le
procès de faire appel du jugement elles
sont pas d'accord et tout d'un coup elle
sorte bah en fait il n'y a absolument
rien dans le dossier aucun témoignage ma
mère en fait est une menteuse une
affabulatrice tout est inventé est sorti
de son imagination fertile
je n'ai jamais rencontré donc
yves montand ma mère non plus enfin bref
il n'ya plus rien dans dossier en fait
c'est à dire que et pourtant la cour
d'appel
pas si aveugle que ça va accepter leur
requête complètement infondées et c'est
elle en fait qu'ils vont nous entraîner
sur l'histoire donc de l'exhumation
puisqu'en fait la parole officiel a fait
croire que c'était moi qui ai fait des
tas déterré mon père pour prouver qu'il
était donc j'étais sa fille quoi
alors que j'avais gagné donc nous en
réalité c'est carole amiel et catherine
alegre qui ont fait déterré longtemps
pour prouver que je n'étais pas sa fille
ce n'est pas la même chose déjà alors
toute la famille d'yves montand ses
descendants toujours refusé de
reconnaître comme une des leurs benjamin
vous l'avez vous savez moi je trouve moi
je comprends ça ça sa détresse et je
comprends toi là pour être précis avant
d'arriver à l'exhumation il ya eu un
test entre les dia valentin et vous
mettrez alors on peut savoir qui alors
l'idéal c'était la soeur de mon temps
balancer son fils et donc aux aurores et
effectivement ce test là disait qu'à 99
9% vous n'étiez pas la fille de dee
montant donc sur ce test là les jeunes
auraient pu en rester là visiblement la
procédure a continué de votre fait
visiblement ce qui a conduit
effectivement plus tard ma mère et moi
ma mère et carole aller jusqu'au bout
mais moi je moi je suis partagé parce
que votre détresse je la comprends il ya
certainement des éléments qui sont
vraies c'est vrai que voilà je veux vous
croit bien volontiers sauf que
malheureusement parce que c'est un fait
maintenant scientifique et et génétique
malheureusement votre deuil réel de
votre père aujourd'hui il est impossible
parce que j'imagine bien que dans votre
cas d'avoir été d'abord d'abord d'abord
été on comprenait 10 alors à l'époque
l'avenir quel est mon temps était
condamnée parce qu'il a effectivement
refusé de faire un test mais ça je vous
dis pourquoi parce que les hommes étant
ce qu'ils sont et surtout mon temps à
cette époque là si toutes les femmes
qu'il a rencontrées a demandé un test
génétique serait très compliqué donc ça
c'était normal qu'ils qui le refusent et
après il était condamné sur une
ressemblance entre guillemets physique
avec des éléments factuels effectivement
moi vous dire que moi je vous le dis moi
je n'ai jamais je n'avais jamais entendu
parler ni de potes ma borne et de vous
avant que le fameux procès et ma mère
non plus après moi je génère j'ai envie
que de vous croire malheureusement
aujourd'hui les faits scientifiques sont
ce qu'ils sont et que la science a dit
voilà quand on fait un test génétique et
qui dit qu'à alors pour le coup quand on
a déterré mon temps c'était même plus
qu'à travailler avec neuf c'était 100%
la détresse aller absolue et moi je
comprends très bien votre détresse en
plus vous en parlait assez joliment et
voilà et aucun homme n'est menée par
fait donc je comprends très bien
aujourd'hui même encore maintenant vingt
ans après parce qu'il ya eu il ya eu un
jugement pour vous battre vous n'avez
aucun doute moi j'ai aucun de ses patins
pour le tente non j'ai aucun doute parce
qu'il ya eu deux tests il ya eu un
premier test avec les yeux un premier
test qui disait que eric qu'elle n'était
pas sa fille à 90 nord il ya eu un
forfait ce qu'a dit que c'était sa fille
non
c'était une enquête voilà alors c'est
vrai que sur une enquête je suis désolé
mais sur une enquête on peut très bien
dire voilà at elle a rencontré un tel
pourquoi pas et c'est vrai ce que vous
rencontrez quelqu'un que vous coucher
avec quelqu'un et vous vivez quelqu'un
je suis désolé que pour autant le fruit
de ça c'est un enfant s'ils allaient un
enfant ça il faut aussi longtemps du
côté de mon temps vous vous voyez ce que
je l'étais quand même établi qu'elle
était sa maîtresse me rends moi j'ai
rien de maths est très sain je vous
remets pas en cause et que vous ayez été
levée avec cette image moi je vous
franchement j'ai beaucoup d'empathie
pour vous et je n'ai jamais eu aucune
animosité contre vous si je dois en
avoir c'est plus plus sur votre mère
parce que je trouve que l'acharnement
qui était suez de votre mère parce
qu'elle avait certainement des
certitudes elle a voulu aller jusqu'au
bout mais je comprends mais mettez-vous
à la place soucier de ma mère était la
première confidente de mon temps et de
vins et de nous ça a été aussi très
compliqué parce qu'effectivement je vous
laisse aux cantons quand on arrive à
devoir déterré le cadavre de quelqu'un
pour prouver parce que je vous dis la
vérité si je vous dis la vérité mon
temps je ne connaissais très bien et je
pense que s'il était votre grand père
non mais oui mais je connaissais
vraiment très très bien j'étais très
produit jusque jusqu'à sa mort forme et
que je ne suis pas génétiquement le fils
de mon temps mais montoir reconnu ma
mère officiellement
voilà je suis donc vous êtes qui
juridiquement je suis juré du bourg
juridiquement son petit fils mais pas
génétiquement parlant voilà un accord
n'est pas mon vrai grand père j'ai rien
compris bah si c'est pas sûr c'est pas
plus bêtes que vous n'êtes je vais
prendre un stylo qui ce que vous avez
très bien compris aux phoques votre mère
c'est votre mère la mère était rose à
mamers pourtant reconnu ma mère marie
longtemps reconnu votre merde comme s'il
n'y a pas trop de sang neuf dans mes
veines faisait quoi ya pas de sens de
mon temps dans les veines un d'accord
c'est mon grand père mon grand père
c'est yves allégret
chez pas jusqu'au bout connais pas très
bien
je n'ai pas lu mon livre non non mais
c'est parti à lui juste la partie nord
jusqu'à vous m'insultez non c'était un
précédent le dernier à gruissan va
bassamat vous vouliez dire quelque chose
à vous dire que c'est important parce
que c'est vrai comment elle a vécu moi
je serais très capital pourra être mis à
l'essai interne elle sait qu'elle est
sincère dans sa démarche allait sincère
elle a envie de connaître son papa et on
peut la comprendre et c'est vrai que
benjamin j'aime vous avez vous avez
parlé mais qu auront là pendant ce
moment la pub et qui si vous êtes dit
quand même pas parce que le grand cheval
de bataille de d'aurore et de sa mère
c'est de dire que les tests n'ont pas
été faits dans la règle dans les règles
de l'art et cetera que bon moi je suis
pas rentrer dans cette polémique il y
avait aussi moyen de 2 de contester
cette dernière
deux derniers tests génétiques vous
l'avez pas fait et vous aviez contester
le précédent donc moi je vous dis
franchement je encore une fois je
comprends tellement je comprends
tellement que vous soyez déçu que ce
soit une situation horrible quand on a
passé vingt ans ou même plus en étant
persuadé que quelqu'un est votre père
est de devoir accepter que ça ne l'est
pas même si dans vos têtes je pense que
j'ai compris pour vous c'est votre père
il n'y a pas de doute là dessus c'est
tout ce que j'avais vécu voilà vous avez
noté une conviction et c'est très dur
c'est très normal après voilà
juridiquement tout ça est évidemment on
va pas se mentir aussi soyons honnêtes
il y avait en jeu à l'héritage
évidemment évidemment dans les villes
sur les tables etc quand j'étais avec
bien sûr et après c'était évident que
mon temps de son vivant n'aurait jamais
pu se accepter un test venant d'une
femme parce que s'ils avaient dit oui
une fois il avait dit oui 20 fois et ça
c'était sont bas et il était condamné
essentiellement parce qu'il a refusé
parce que qui ne fut qu est d'ailleurs
fait jurisprudence matin un père qui
refuse la thèse génétique aujourd'hui il
est il est condamné
pour ça donc ça il ya vraiment eu un
impact sur ce que vous pouvez dire habré
soit vous qui êtes persuadé que vous
êtes la fille de son grand père bachir
encore une fois j'ai vraiment envie de
l'inviter à consulter du coup mon site
internet et ou alors ma page officielle
afin d'avoir au moins d'affaires la
version avec méfaits
mais en toute honnêteté en toute
intelligence façon honnête je ressente
vraiment que vous êtes honnête j'ai
aucun doute là-dessus mais je le dis
dans ma famille s'il y avait eu il y
avait une condamnation aussi ici montant
avait eu le moindre doute je pense qu'il
aurait été au bout du bout des
opérations ce n'était pas quelqu'un qui
se défile et forcément devant ciel c'est
la possibilité mais voilà c'est une
sombre affaire ça a été compliqué pour
tout le monde c'était compliqué très
compliqué et la vraie victime de tout ça
la tique une victime dans l'histoire
c'est vous auront malheureusement parce
que vous êtes là vous êtes celles qui
étaient en attente d'une nouvelle qui
n'a pas été celle que vous souhaitiez et
c'est terrible je peux je ne peux que
être compatissant et être aimé être avec
vous je vous livre sincèrement parce que
c'est c'est terrible et en plus vous
êtes sincère et vous êtes persuadé que
c'est votre père mais la justice et la
génétique en a décidé autrement donc je
je je ne peux que vous dire je suis je
suis désolé parce que parce que c'est
une situation qui est invivable voilà
maintenant j'ai dépassé néanmoins tout
ça voilà le temps et tant mieux
aujourd'hui c'est autre chose
oui j'ai largement dépassé ça j'ai mené
on va dire un combat intérieur puisque
bonjour j'ai envie de mourir ont quand
même de mes 6 ans mais 29 ans donc c'est
pas rien à cause des deux sauts roger
perpétuelle de mon père est ensuite de
la société même quand vous avez vu que
moi qui ont été primés dadis est ce que
vous avez essayé de le joindre aussi
pour lui en parler ou pas du tout pas du
tout pas du tout moi n'ont pas la main
aux gens dossier du tout j'avais pas la
peine en même temps et pour vous en
parler même comme ça n'ont jamais passé
exactement il à l'écouté c'est vrai que
même valentin en fait j'ai un g j'ai mis
mon nom
j'étais sur facebook en tout cas j'ai
laissé la porte ouverte pour que si
quelqu'un veuille venir me voir me poser
des questions eh bien je suis là ouverte
pour y répondre
voilà j'ai pas d'animosité
ballan pas comme vous il est comme vous
c'est il est élevé dans l'hypothèse
inverse celle qu'on a passé son temps à
dire que vous n'étiez pas sa soeur et
donc ses sentrys c'est l'amalgamé fait
miroir c'est la même chose pour lui il
peut pas elle peut pas maintenant vous
tendre la main ce serait pas possible
s'est il a été élevé dans l'été le vit
comme ça comme avait été levée dans le
souvenir d'adapter hypothétique donc ça
où pour le coup moi pas le seul à pierre
justo rend votre maman est ce que pour
elle il ya zéro doute ils vont donc de
renouer votre père ya un verrou n'a pas
il n'ya pas le doute sur un autre homme
à nankin par terreau de ces sales
histoires est ce que c'est la vraie
question si on était sur le point d'y
aller ll que des relations qu'avec mon
temps cette période vraiment donc
vraiment c'est impossible d'ailleurs à
800 grammes c'est ça c'est ça c'est
incroyable ça c'est une vraie question
parce que c'est vrai que si vous me
disiez si votre mère disait voilà
j'étais chez lui voilà pendant peut-être
cette année là j'ai eu plusieurs mais
même dans la semaine les mois où ça va
plus puisque c'est en vacances à venir
sur excel va voir yves montand il lui
dit viens tout de suite à bien toutes
ces d'après la vie et continue c'est pas
ça c'est une vraie question que tu poses
il ya eu des contre enquêtes c'est alors
il ya eu des pistes ont été ont été
ouvertes justement de du côté de dettes
de la défense pourra si votre maman
avait pas eu quelqu'un d'autre mais moi
je trouve que ces voiles à faire passer
voilà on va on va pas rentrer maintenant
je trouve c'est trop trop tard et moi je
souhaite qu'une chose très honnêtement
c'est que vous alliez bien que vous
allez mieux mais votre maman là à lui et
personne d'autre non non vraiment moi
j'ai vécu vraiment sans aucune image
paternelle en fait non mais j'en ai
avant périodes là
non vraiment c'est est amoureuse total
selon moi il ya zéro doute ah oui c'est
redoute donc quand vous il ya zéro doute
pour vous vous allez vivre tout le
restant d'audi donc maintenant c'est
vous david et puis aussi parce que j'ai
vécu vraiment des trucs de incroyable
c'est à dire que quelqu'un en toute
honnêteté qui vraiment intègre dès le
départ qu'ils qui est vraiment de bonne
foi moi j'ai quand on a subi quand même
des des pressions extérieures on a eu
des témoins deux témoins issus du cinéma
claude sautet henri colpi qui ont subi
des menaces pour changer leur version
j'ai reçu un moment un témoignage info
télégramme au moment de la deuxième
convocation pour le test adn avec yves
montand
c'est un photographe au télégramme
disant que le rendez vous était annulée
qu'il fallait pas qu'on se présente
signé l'expert dr marc shelly d'accord
ma mère appelle non non le rendez-vous
est totalement maintenu j'ai jamais
envoyé le télégramme en fait ça a été
des choses comme ça non-stop j'ai même
eu un moment un garde du corps parce
qu'on venait jusqu'à chez nous pour nous
faire peur pour qu'on arrête le procès
donc en fait ça a été ça non-stop en
réalité donc
je ne peux être que largement sûr que
c'est mon père parce que je vois pas
pourquoi il y aurait mis autant mais
autant d'ardeur à tout faire pour nous
faire lâcher en fait c'est hallucinant
en fait ça a été pour moi un combat je
trouve à mort déloyale à partir du
moment où j'ai j'ai gagné ce procès en
94 tout ce qui a suivi derrière mais ça
a été enfin ouais c'est vraiment hard
pour vous il ya des pressions ça a été
il a fait à oui oui oui gérard là je
peux vous affirmer confirmer tout ce que
vous voulez oui